now here a 20 year old man has been
charged under the treason act after an
incident in the grounds of windsor
castle last christmas jazwan singh chale
who's from southampton is accused of
carrying a crossbow and making threats
to kill let's bring in our crime
correspondent martin brunt and martin
treason is a pretty rare
charge tell us more about this case
yes this is a rare charge but it's not
unique and you have to go back to
1981 to see the last prosecution when a
teenager called marcus sergeant
admitted firing six blanks at the queen
as she rode at trooping of the color
he admitted the charge and was jailed
for five years um i can't remember
anything um before
1981
but to get back
uh to what's happened today the crown
prosecutors have charged uh that 20 year
old man as he is now he was 19 at the
time
um the police said at the time
of his arrest
that he was found within moments of
entering the grounds of windsor castle
the queen was spending christmas there
that was unusual she normally spends
christmas at sandringham she was made
aware
of his presence he was arrested a
crossbow was found according to police
at the time but he did not end to any of
the buildings at windsor castle so he
faces
three charges now um one of a threat to
kill another of possession of an
offensive weapon
and it's that third charge that's
creating all the interest and these are
the wording of it
being near to the person of the queen
willfully producing a loaded crossbow
with intent to use the same to injure
the person of her majesty
contrary to section two of the treason
act
1842 so there you are a bit wordy um mr
chael will
be held in custody until his next court
appearance which will be
in a couple of weeks time 17th of august
at westminster magistrates court
martian thank you very much